hey you're here with the russell check
me out on the bootleg cab podcast
bullet cat podcast special guest in here
my guy representing north vallejo
man the russell is here come on dog
welcome welcome welcome man sir hey man
so give me like you know for people who
don't know man kind of give everyone a
little kind of like run down on your
background how long you've been making
music and you know just where you're
from you know
man i'm from norfolk california uh
[ __ ]
background wise i've probably been doing
music since i was like
probably started rapping since i was
like seven or eight just like rapping
with my sister you know we're like beats
and instrumentals and [ __ ] from line
wire [ __ ] like that
and i probably really start taking it
serious in like 2018 i dropped my first
project called the field effect and then
from there we just been kind of like
rolling rolling
so
vallejo you know is a
historical hip-hop city
there's been some legends out of vallejo
yes sir um the bay area in general is
such a like
i always refer to the bay as like own
thing it's like it's like his own
country within a country right
especially within hip hop right
like there's so much base [ __ ] like
you'll go to the bay and you'll go to
the club and like if you have like
you're not like up on what's hot right
they'll be like songs that aren't even
from the bay that are like getting
played out there that only worked there
right you know what i'm saying but like
it's it's a it's his own world man like
and
you know obviously the bigger artists
from the bay that we know e40 mac dre uh
you know
hers and [ __ ] legend already
yeah shout out to g eazy shout out to
kailani um
where it like you know there's there's
the other other side of the coin which
is like jairo and
and uh dale and all those guys um who
really had the 90s on smash but like
did you pull from any of the
more traditional bay area music because
i don't get that from from when i listen
to your [ __ ] i don't really get a lot of
a lot of um
well people would consider bay area
vibes right i mean
i i give a little bit of both but yeah i
get that a lot like i get a lot of love
from the east coast because you know
like they [ __ ] with like rapping and
bars but uh definitely i mean i came up
on 40 and dre and sure like my mom's a
huge too short family two shorts that
guy i was rapping freaky tails when i
was five you feel me shout out to your
mom for playing freaky tales around you
when you were five months man playing
freaky tails and cocktails yeah you feel
me but now i came up heavy on the bait
on the base [ __ ] but i also had like a
mix of everything else like my pops
played a little bit of everything so i
was hearing
hole hearing nas and and pop you feel me
is that the kind of stuff that like you
gravitated towards
more the lyrical [ __ ] i i think uh
yeah just naturally just because like
that music
just resonates a bit more at times like
you feel me as a kid when you hear a
dear mama and you hear only god can
judge me like you you don't know what's
happening but you know that something is
different you know i mean like the just
the content matter is a bit different
right so it definitely like it just hits
home a little bit more
um
your comp so talk about all your videos
your good company
come on give me
give me uh education on on this on what
gc is what does it mean so uh gc stands
for good company and uh basically i
started this company probably about 2017
2018
and we're just like uh basically like
here to help artists you feel me in the
bay like i didn't really have any um
backing or support like outside when i
was growing my [ __ ] i couldn't get
people to like help me and help me with
play all this extra [ __ ] playlist and
just none of that so we start kind of
figuring out the game and doing it
ourselves and i kind of got with my
homies and we just started building a
platform to where we're like
if an artist does need help and we love
what they're doing we're able to assist
and accommodate in certain areas whether
that be like marketing content ads
playlists and [ __ ] like that and it's
and it's it it's its own platform right
so like you go to the youtube page and
there's right so we have a live
performance session platform but we also
do just a bunch of other content and we
kind of started we started the live
performance platform uh last december
and it's kind of like you know like
colors genius
[ __ ] like that just our own in our home
because like
man we had to go we had to go everywhere
to do everything you feel me it's like
every time we had to shoot something we
had to go to [ __ ] l.a right right
york or frisco yeah so i was like big on
bringing that home and doing it we
actually went to uh vevo in 2019 and
shot some content with them and i was
telling my team i'm like bro we got to
go home and do this ourselves like we it
shouldn't be we shouldn't have to fly
across the country
to do it so like that was a plan and we
kind of really went home and just made
that [ __ ] shake yeah you were saying
like uh
it's dope because obviously
vallejo is not a place that like
people who aren't from the bay frequent
right so you're bringing a lot of like
attention and just traffic to like a
friend we didn't have some of the
biggest execs in the game coming to
vallejo which has never happened you
feel me pulling up to the crib like
there was a point where i stopped like
taking meetings flying i'm like i'm not
going to do no meetings you got to come
to the crib if you want to talk to me
and like just that is so different
because we've never bro if you're not
going to marine world you ain't coming
to vallejo you feel me so now we have
artists who are like prominent and
bubbling and established coming to the v
to work with us you feel me and like
that's a big stamp for vallejo and the
culture just something different that
we've never had like we literally have
to go everywhere for everything if you
just want to eat great food you damn
near got to go somewhere you feel me so
it's like wait wait so you're saying
that the the food in valeno is not great
no the food is smacking but it's like
the options are limited like bro where
we're a city with [ __ ]
four or five exits you feel me like if
you want like all the i like you
frisco you can find everything you want
everything
kind of yeah give me that like you know
obviously for people who don't know the
bear is broken up into a lot of
different parts right you know obviously
there's oakland
uh there's
frisco brick yeah
so like what what do you think makes
cause vallejo like i said you know shout
out to like nefta pharaoh 40. valeo's a
huge
part as far as just the
historical context of barrier hip-hop
music but what do you think makes
vallejo different than the rest of the
bay i think it's because we're
integrated but also separate you know
like we're very
like once you cross the bridge
everything is kind of together like
emeryville
oakland uh you got like hey where all of
that [ __ ] is like you feel me it's like
connected berkeley it's all like right
there within each other vallejo it's
like
just it's just us here you you feel me
there's no connection and i think with
that we've been able to develop
everything uniquely because it's like
we're not tied into nothing so
everything that comes out the v is fresh
like it's only here you can only get
this [ __ ] here the sound the style
everything you feel me the sauce like
bro
it's just a different energy you feel me
and people are really prideful about it
as well like you don't meet too many
people from vallejo who isn't like if
you meet somebody from vallejo they're
going to let you know they're from
vallejo right no that's for sure that
that [ __ ] gonna come up
period yeah no that's facts or they're
like they're they're like shout out my
guy ken his instagram is vallejo cam
like bro he obviously this [ __ ]
in atlanta and he's talking about
vallejo yeah right bro you feel me
because it's really it's it's the water
like we're we're a stand-alone city you
feel me like to come from frisco you got
to cross two bridges to get in vallejo
you feel me and we're both in the bay
area but we're just like a stand-alone
city has there been any like of the
bay area ogs that have like tapped in
with you yet
yeah for sure like 40 uh man 40 is cool
as [ __ ]
he's the best you know e40 is like one
of the few guys you'll meet him and
you'll be like this is exactly who i
hoped you would be mad bro exactly man i
had a ball before you like he's exactly
who you are especially when he's off
that wine or that tequila boy
but yeah if all he tapped in and then um
uh
who tapped in with me um
it's been a few years
man yeah that's a legend
yeah
um
it's been a few bruh it's been a few but
yeah it's just been love like everybody
is now starting to kind of show love and
not even just oh geez like some of the
younger ones pete lo taps in yeah
pillows
uh did e40 try to sign you to to stick
with it nah he thought he ain't shot us
on me before he was i was a light bro
i'm i'm here whatever you trying to do
whatever you need me but now he didn't
try to sign i always tell 40 like when
his albums come out but like bro who the
[ __ ] says no to you bro cause this
[ __ ] will put a triple out mouth
with everybody in the game
bro i'm like bro who says no to e40
right if this will calls
they're gonna say yes right and like
you'll see the tracklist like yep
everyone say yes
exactly exactly i mean he's a cultural
icon for sure he's a cultural and one of
the most underrated mcs ever facts facts
i'd be more heavier than a hippopotamus
get off in your head like a neurologist
shout out to 40 man um so with what
you're doing it's like very very uh
it's unconventional as far as like oh i
love your approach with like the music
or the freestyles you drop
they could be found on spotify yeah they
can be found everywhere you do your
freestyles over original music it's j it
just it i feel like you're you're you're
kind of approaching
the the rap [ __ ]
you know everyone always talks about
content first content first content
first but yet when they drop content
they don't really ultraly monetize it
the way they should be right you know
what i mean like right
everybody can do a freestyle over who
shot you by biggie but you you can't get
paid off it you know what i'm saying you
don't own it what was your uh
motivation to kind of approaching
some of the content you do in that way
where you can initial really just kind
of if you have a moment where
charlemagne posts your freestyle people
can go listen to it on spotify let alone
youtube i mean that was my thing and
really it was like a way for me to be
able to like pay all my [ __ ] and like
just everybody who helps me and
contributes you feel me
like everything we work on i'm just like
bro we need it accessible everywhere so
it's like
wherever that revenue comes from we
could be able to split it and break it
down you feel me and that was like a big
thing to me like i had a i had a crazy
moment when i i've just been figuring
out the game the past few years and when
i was looking and i'm like
damn bro people are working on music
videos people are shooting this kind of
thing people are doing this and it's
going viral
and
they don't own it and they're not
getting paid and the people who worked
on it aren't getting paid and the only
person who's getting paid is whoever
monetized it on youtube you know like
and that [ __ ] was just nuts to me and i
had a big moment like i had to go redo a
lot of stuff like just making sure
everybody is good and straight you feel
me so so when you say taking care of
every so like do you give your cameraman
a split on the joint i give everybody if
you hold the [ __ ] light in my video
you're going to get a percentage if you
any anything you feel me like if you
contributed to something we've created
or done you're going to get all the live
sessions we're doing good company we
break down all that bread if you
engineer record you edit the artist the
producer like if you find the projection
that we use if you send me an artist
like i had a lot of homies who sent me
artists like like hey this is dope if we
end up bringing them on i'm giving you a
percentage you feel me it wouldn't
happen without you and it's like this
game
for some reason doesn't work like that i
got a boy who works on a lot of big
music videos right we were talking and
i'm like hey am i what do you own any of
that and he's like nah and i'm like bro
you've done a hundred of them
what do you mean like some of these have
millions of views and the artist blew up
off the video why don't you own any of
it that [ __ ] don't make no sense even
like engineers and like people who like
bro
i think engineer is probably the most
underappreciated person in the musical
process bro yes because and it's it
sucks because his game has been built
around like a payola system or just i
gotta eat system that it's like
[ __ ] don't want a percentage they
rather you just pay them but it's like i
don't like i don't charge for anything i
do like any thing you see what i do with
artists if i help write put out a record
market any i put my bread up behind
artists i don't charge for nothing i
just want a percent for what i work for
i feel like there's no price worth what
i'm doing so a feature you hit me for a
feature like everyone's how much you try
for a feature it's like i don't if i
don't love it i'm just not going to do
it yeah you feel me and this game has
been twisted like nobody's operating off
that everybody want their bread and it's
like that [ __ ] cool but like i'm really
trying to like build something long-term
like i'll be damned if something make 10
million dollars and i helped create it
and you ain't getting nothing yeah
nothing not even five percent no you're
right especially with like these young
directors right they'll shoot a video
just for free most of the time i rule
and it goes like the artist blows up
yeah and the only [ __ ] who ain't got
paid is the person who made it yeah
i need a nap
approach to the game man
so right now obviously
you're
you know you've had a lot of dope
moments over the last few months um
i know charlemagne is a big fan of yours
and and he doesn't co-sign a lot of new
artists man shout out charlemagne man
charlemagne shows crazy love like
organic natural facts he's one of the
most organic naturally just amazing
dudes i know man charlemagne shows so
much love that [ __ ] think that i'm
paying him the post now they think he's
doing a promo for labor so that's so
funny that's just insane you know but
he's like he's someone who like really
supports it gets behind it like where
did where do you where did he uh like
what do you know kind of the origin of
like how he discovered your [ __ ] oh
vayne so hopefully shout out to hovain
hoebane's a great guy man man
is the guy yeah that's my guy he'd be
making some questionable fashion
decisions sometimes but well you know
listen hoban's a bigger guy so he you
know there's certain [ __ ] that probably
ain't made in his size it's the east
coast [ __ ] man it's just different out
there man shout out trigg one [ __ ] had
on uggs with the uh knitted top wait ho
vane had it uggs on wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait wait wait no
no no no i gotta say i will roast that
man right now but you you feel me like
hope ain't no baby
don't let me find out how they got uggs
bro cause i will never let that probably
got a breath i i put some
charlemagne and uh charlemagne [ __ ]
with it heavy like helvane has been a
big part in just like a lot of what's
been happening hovan's great man are you
working with ovane yeah well vain's the
best i've been knowing hoevane since uh
early troy have days
early or i was one of the bigger uh so i
would probably the biggest supporter of
troy have low key early on man and love
troy have [ __ ] yeah
and then things got weird and i really
you know i didn't really agree with the
way uh
i i know jovane and i know he's a great
guy you know what i'm saying so when all
that [ __ ] kind of transpired i'm like
bro like i seen this guy hold you down
bro
jovan's good people though that's dope
man yeah i mean you got a great guy
behind you then yeah yeah he's a great
guy and then also kind of like he's in
new york and
you're in the bay is kind of both sides
of the country online right we're
touching both ends and that's the thing
like i'm i feel like as a bay area
artist like we don't often get that east
coast support
and a lot of my a lot of people who
champion me like early wallow russ
mcmill all of them you feel me they're
on the east coast you feel me so it's
like dope to have both sides kind of
supporting and getting behind them
wallows so far man i love mine that was
a real [ __ ] millions of dollars where
the game is my favorite podcast wallow
wallow with someone uh wallow supported
like very early and like pushing the
line and i end up giving him a percent
of some [ __ ] because it really changed
my life you may help me and it's like
things like that wait
okay okay so give me so you gave wallow
percentage of what
a record yeah okay a record okay exactly
i gave him a percentage of a record
because he like really
wallow was one of the reasons like some
[ __ ] really blew
up like everything changed i was getting
a call from every [ __ ] label in the
world that morning and i was like bro
like you deserve a percentage you feel
me if i was with a label they would be
taking hella so you feel me like i had
to it was a
easy call for me yeah no he was a good
he's a great guy being able to break
down the pie and do splits it's like it
allows me to do [ __ ] like that when
[ __ ] really come in and like help me
to just
bro you feel me like that's something
long term
in [ __ ] 10 years i feel like i'll be
one of the biggest artists in the world
that percent is gonna be a real stop do
you feel me right hey what up man we
gotta interrupt the interview real quick
to tell you about our family at odd
socks now when i be riding for odd socks
so hard man it's because i really love
the product they got the most
comfortable socks in the [ __ ] world i
got a pair of odd socks basics on right
now go get those they got the socks wwe
joints you know i'm saying shout out to
the undertaker pepsi [ __ ]
really whatever you need some weed socks
nickelodeon but really they got the
draws now ladies and gentlemen
i'm holding a pair of tapatio underwear
right now
you want some pop tarts on your dick pop
tart draws and these [ __ ] are
so comfortable
like
man so listen you gotta go to
oddssoxofficial.com
and use the uh promo code the discount
code bootleg kev
at oddssocksofficial.com you'll save 20
off underwear the most comfortable socks
in the world crazy licenses not only
they got the wwe they got the scarface
they got the street fighter they got the
nickelodeon they got it all so make sure
you hit that website oddsoxofficial.com
save 20 off with the promo code bootleg
kev all right go do that shout out to
odd socks let's get back to the
interview what is uh
a moment that you've had over the last
like five or six months where you kind
of opened your phone and saw and were
like oh what this is crazy
man
like this person reposting my [ __ ] or
this person like my [ __ ] this is crazy
like you know i think we all kind of get
that
i don't even know if i could say it yet
but i met i've i've had some big uh
another another big one that was like
dope to me uh mark pitts had reached out
you know mark pitch is legend legend
yeah biggie of course
bro so that was that was when i was like
damn bro this is insane it's really
reaching you feel me like when you say
you know the other one you couldn't you
you can't sit talk about yet is it uh
because there's a collab coming
or
it's it's some it's some crazy [ __ ] in
the works right how crazy
as crazy as like like give me give me an
idea
man i'm gonna see if i can guess
i i even if you guess i you won't know
you feel me just crazy so you and
kendrick working together
there it is kendrick lamar yeah
right you guys got a record on that l.a
russell and kendrick lamar
on the way
on the way come on you heard it here you
heard it here
hey
it's funny too because i saw you post
the joe budden thing
and i thought that was so funny right it
was like
obviously he was talking about you right
did you have any did joe budden reach
out to you at all no he didn't he didn't
reach out i actually had a fan of mine
hit me and was like bro i think he's
talking about he's got to be talking
which is dope like yeah me like a lot of
moments i i miss because i don't really
be watching like pogba i'd be like
working like putting [ __ ] together
yeah like they sent me and was like he's
definitely talking about you so i've
seen i'm like man that's dope you feel
me i love joe budden fish but just
showing the love that he did show in a
very joe budding way you feel me in a
very joe budding way that a very joe
burning way you feel me but for i i know
for him that that took a lot you feel me
so it's like that [ __ ] cool and he's not
giving that co-sign to a lot of people
you feel me
who has been the
i i'm assuming
oh we were talking off the camera you've
had a lot of people trying to sign you
yeah obviously right has there been like
a an artist that's tried to sign you yet
yeah
yeah we actually got got like a
situation now from an artist that's like
really
great
something you're considering something
i'm actually considering like he gave me
a really great offer to just like to
stay independent and to just be a part
of something big which is like dope to
me because
he's someone who came in early and was
like bro i really want to help and
assist and we've been just trying to
talk about ways to do that and like bro
he really structured he really gave me
an opportunity to say i what do you want
you feel me and i'm like man this is
what would help me he's like bro let's
do it you feel me as don't have to don't
have all the [ __ ] major label
[ __ ] that you gotta deal with like
it's an incredible deal
like bro and it came from an artist
which to me was just like bro that's
interesting is this an artist that has a
track record of
of
you have any successful label no no he
doesn't even have a label this is an
artist who just has a track record of
being successfully independent and doing
this [ __ ] and right now he's developing
a label but it's not even about the
label it's just about like bro i need to
help damn so
what's it like working with russ
that's hilarious
it's to be russ it is bro it is
wrestling shout out shout out russell
yeah we got we got some [ __ ] that we
considering and just looking at it man
russ i always help champion russ and try
to give him his flowers cause like he
literally is giving everyone like
you know we were just talking about uh
wallow but he's giving people millions
of dollars worth a game like russ
it's crazy because russ is like if like
showing everyone the way bro
and people are [ __ ] weirdos or
they're haters or they you know they
don't like the messenger
russ is
is a real [ __ ] like and i'm just gonna
say it like bro he he supported early
and he told me early on like bro i'm
gonna figure out a way how i can get in
an assistant he really like held us in
like even with the offer like bro a lot
of offers i got from labels the first
offers were like bro are you [ __ ]
kidding me like bruh stop talking to me
russ really came correct from the get-go
and he was like look at it whatever you
think should be changed let me know like
i sent this [ __ ] a long ass message to
like i don't everything he's like let's
switch it all you feel me like there was
nothing that he wasn't willing to do
because he's really like bro he gave me
a deal that is like very artist
favorable
as he would like
you know like he does he's got he's got
to practice what he preaches right man
bro and it's incredible to see like an
artist do it because i've gotten offers
from majors and it's like bro are y'all
are y'all nuts you feel me so it's like
he's definitely just showed a lot of
real love and support and you could tell
that he really [ __ ] with it and has
passion because the offer reflects that
you feel
it's easy for people to come and say oh
we love what you're doing we want to
help this is but you get an offer and
it's like this don't look like what
y'all told me like this [ __ ] really
looked like what he told me and it's
funny on the phone i told him i said bro
everything sounds amazing on this phone
i don't want to get a contract
and now i don't understand what we're
talking about you feel me so like i'm
somebody i don't believe all that music
industry [ __ ] having 50 page contracts
like bro that [ __ ] is dead
if i if i'm talking to you right now and
i understand everything then i get a
contract and now i'm confused something
wrong i don't even want to look at it
bro like something but the thing with
russ is like he always preaches that
right like you shouldn't you know i feel
like he's just giving everyone the way
it's like yo you should never pay a
lawyer ten percent like you should never
give like you should never give up this
much just for people to hit upload like
all these things are like man bro
bro what's crazy is i'm waiting for
drake to listen to russ and just go
independent and break the whole [ __ ]
industry man bro and he needs to but
drake is also someone who like doesn't
need to be independent because like
republic don't run them that bad they're
going to run him
stupid keep running in that bag
like why wouldn't you he would break the
record industry if he went independent i
think
yeah because i don't think and no one's
ever really like at that level
said all right i'm going independent
right i mean he's the biggest artist in
the world like well i wonder what
kendrick's about to do
uh like with it being that this is the
last album like i'm i'm sure he'll go
india after like it just wouldn't make
any sense well i know that baby keem is
on him and dave freeze labels
and they're
coming through
columbia sony right so i'd only assume
if kendrick is going to
i mean i don't know i'm just assuming at
this point oh no though right because
drake got ovo ovo's not under ovo's over
at warner right
but straight to that republic but yeah
but kendrick's labels over i think at
columbia or at least baby keem is yeah
so i don't know if kendrick was
independent it'd be [ __ ] insane
insane
i don't know
any of them if any of them do it you
feel me it'd be like i'd be like one of
those three guys you know like kendrick
or drake it's got to be one of the three
yeah one of those three goes to india so
it's it's like gonna just
expose
what
i mean what russ has been saying this
whole time bro
and russ is genius brad like he knows
for sure
i should do a [ __ ] podcast or
something man like once a month did you
hit him he'll do it i just think he did
a podcast even it was once a month right
because his interviews man you could
watch a russ interview and come away
like damn i'm inspired i got some game
right he tossed some [ __ ] ownership just
the way man it's like bro that's dope
though so you're so
are you going to be like working with
him on releasing music together
man we have we got some [ __ ] in the
works and then yeah just like man he's
just been like a good just help figure
for whatever like if i reach out like i
could literally call him whenever and
if he brings you on tour that'd be a
confusing flyer
man that'd be a crazy flyer we'll look
like hit and play
hello russell
right now that'd be fire though
you guys got some unreleased music
together
man we got we we it's man
you got that project with us
who knows
who knows man that chomp ep was crazy
man right man hopefully he puts me on
top too rusty you see this
hey man you fit the bill right i want
him to do like cause i know he like self
produces everything
um i would love for russ to just go like
tapping with the alchemist for like 10
10 records
just do like a whole like if he does
chomp just do with one producer right
and it'd be like a legendary like late
like alchemist or even like harry fraud
or some [ __ ] like that that [ __ ] would
be crazy so talk about your relationship
marlin seven and
your relationship with tope who's here
come on man shout out to man portland in
the building oh you from portland
portland in a building
uh i just met tope this year like in
[ __ ] february or something like he uh
pretty recently i had yeah i had did a
live session for an artist named lucky
and um tope produced a beat so i had to
send him a split and i'm like hey bro
some bread come here this is that right
and uh he ended up hitting me on twitter
and was like brown really trying to work
with the russell that it is i just dm'd
and i'm like let's get it because i had
uh i told myself last year at the end of
last year i'm like i'm gonna try to
collaborate more because i don't work
with people for like the first two three
years right right right i just stuck
with in my team so i'm like let me try
to collaborate more so he pulled up
we did like three or four that first day
in like two and a half three hours right
just knocked him out and uh i told him
i'm like bro i want to make a soundtrack
for my bike rides i had started biking
last year a lot just like going
everywhere i'm like i need a soundtrack
a lot of people did during the pandemic
man we was out man me and the homies all
got bikes and we was really just mobbing
so i was like i want a soundtrack for my
bike rides because like that's where i
really listen to my [ __ ] and man he just
came with the whops and it's like he's
from portland but he's got the bay
sound like it just felt and it's not
even just i feel like the bay in seattle
are like
bay north that's right yeah
you feel me so but it was it was fresh
and uh marlon 7 is the name of the bike
i bought i had end up like going through
a couple of bikes and i ended up getting
one which is the marlin seven which i
love if trek wants to sponsor me and
send me one oh yeah you got to get a
free one for sure right man for certain
like i've i've really given the game but
yeah we end up doing marlin seven
and um i was getting like hella like
just a couple months ago like we've been
holding it for a few months it's been
done and i'm like man it's just i gotta
wait for the right time and i got like
really colluded with everything because
i start kind of blowing up and just one
day i was like [ __ ] this [ __ ] we need to
just drop it like let's just drop this
[ __ ] and we dropped it and it did his
thing like bro it's already over two
hundred thousand streams it's only been
out a couple weeks like it did its thing
yeah i think like two what's stop about
people don't do that [ __ ] no more bro
that's why i think it's been hard about
like
someone like freddie gibbs doing like
doing [ __ ] with madlib i mean he did
that in 2014 for the first time
like alfredo last year like just full
collaborations
when it comes to production and the
artist like
it always to me breeds the best projects
the best bodies will work because it's
like a cohesive thing you know what i'm
saying like right that's just missing
everybody so and i get the single game
but like everything everybody's so like
they feel like they put an album out
they gotta have i gotta have a song for
the girls i gotta have a club record i
gotta have a radio record i gotta do you
know what i mean
it's like bro just put out something
that you can press play on oh we just
make dope [ __ ] and it's like bro we run
it and that's how i'm doing like all of
my projects like all of my next projects
are like with a specific producer and we
kind of just did it top to bottom
because i like the cohesion as well of
that you feel me
what uh who would you say is your
biggest influence as a mc
like if you had a pinpoint one person
where you're like yo man i probably can
contribute the most to my style what
kind of what inspired me
to this one person early on kanye and uh
probably later down the line uh early on
kanye mid j cole and kendrick and later
like drake you feel me
and then
like now
whole for like every time hope does
something i'm like very inspired and
like man when i got older i finally like
listened to hope you like
to the actual albums and i'm just like
what the [ __ ] i'm like it's just
different but yeah i mean them like for
sure kanye is the reason like i started
making beats i had seen a video on
youtube with him like [ __ ] around on
the npc when i was a kid and i just
started i'm like man i want to make
beats from there making beats rapping
that's why a lot of my songs like i'm
always you hear like little comedic you
know type cause like kanye's influence
on me was heavy yeah kanye's i was just
telling uh the homie i was like kanye's
probably my favorite artist ever
bro i was not a i was not a fan of
jesus's king but i love donda
i think yay's got its
high points
man i i i had ghost rooms and listen to
yay and ghost ghost town's one of my
favorite songs ever i think it might be
the best kanye song it's like top five
top 10 kanye song ever man i was on a
come down from a stream trip and i
played ghost town and i was driving and
it was like brad just felt like heaven i
was like bro how the [ __ ] do you make
some [ __ ] like this you know what's
crazy too is like the disrespect that
kids see ghosts gets when people talk
about like
i think kitsy ghost is like
i got it in my probably my top five or
six kanye projects like that [ __ ]
i feel like people were just kind of off
yeah at the time so they don't really
like give yeah they don't give that
album yay enough love and and hey
[Music]
what's your favorite kanye album
uh probably college dropout
fair enough yeah
and that i
mean cause i love graduating beautiful
dad late registered i mean my favorite
is late registration but i think the
best is my beautiful day let's drop out
cause like all falls down is like the
greatest song in the world to me like
that [ __ ] really changed like
i just remember being a kid wrapping it
front to back in a in a back seat like
you know word for word yeah and uh yeah
that [ __ ] really and skits every like
that's what my oh the skits were amazing
the skits were amazing kanye brought
skits like that's the thing is like i
wish he would like get like we haven't
gotten great kanye skits for how long
for a minute bro man he's not the same
kanye man
what do you think of donda different
you know what's funny so like as as like
the more i grow it's like kanye's like
just rapport like slowly comes down to
me i did donda was the first project of
his i didn't rush to
didn't rush to it you feel me and i
started listening and i was like ah
i'm not loving it so i gotta really sit
down again yeah there's some dope [ __ ]
on there i think that uh i felt started
to feel the same way about yay though
yeah it hurt me yeah it's almost like i
used to be like so excited for kanye to
drop and now i'm like
i mean hopefully this [ __ ] don't suck
bro that
that is funny
right that but that's how it feels now
which is like crazy you know i think
that moment for me was the scoop diddy
poop record that's funny i was like ah
nah but kanye is just that he's still
that guy to me for sure like it's just
he's that guy but yeah it's just like
it's slowly
just slowly like you know as you grow
you start to see people there's some
good [ __ ] on donda though man there is
some good [ __ ] on donda i was not a fan
of jesus's king in any capacity there
were some ill beats on there shout out
the books but
yeah you're atheist yes i i
i made this
i i am atheist that's also probably why
i didn't [ __ ] with because i felt like
i love jesus jesus walks right
but i just feel like even donna's
there's a lot of uh
god talk on there but it isn't like it
doesn't feel like forced down your
[ __ ] throat right the jesus is king
[ __ ] with all the like live choirs
of jesus as your lord and savior right
bro this is a lot buddy like this is a
lot that's funny like from somebody
who's like a die-hard kanye fan then the
every [ __ ] tour
i was like well this is just this this
is the first time i've ever heard of
kanye i'm like this [ __ ]
literally isn't for me man them demons
was getting into him boy nah yeah i mean
yeah i didn't i didn't really vote for
jesus as king either like i mean i just
i just feel like
i don't want to grab me for best gospel
album
right so there's that you know i mean
it's kanye
yeah they don't even know who else made
a gospel album that year like that's why
yeah
i love yay man i hope i hope you know i
i kind of like
i always hear like
that
you know you'll hear like people talk
about music he's working on
and like even think about donda right
like how long this album was supposed to
be a thing
like there's i just feel like depending
on where he is at the time i think this
is why we probably got
something way better than donda because
he i feel like he kind of got a chip on
his shoulder he's single
he's working out and [ __ ] lost weight
this [ __ ] is like
you know i i [ __ ] with donda it was
definitely uh
it was refreshing for me to enjoy a
kanye album to be honest you know what
i'm saying yeah you know and plus he
[ __ ] up that nas album you know the ep
i'm about how you [ __ ] fumble at nas
when i heard the nice kanye [ __ ] i'm
like this has got to be a classic
that [ __ ] was mid bro
but during that same run there was
daytona which is one of my favorite
albums ever right shout out to pusha t
yeah so uh listen go check you out
online for people who don't know good
company is the youtube channel
yeah right that's your company it this
is it's obviously a multi-faceted
platform right
so you like sign an artist are you no so
we don't sign nobody but we do
everything that someone who would sign
them do and we don't we don't sign we
just like to we just split it up we
divvy the pie it's like bro we just want
a percent of what we work on we invest
in artists we help create content use
all of our people to help and assist
write songs yeah
i mean it sounds fair to me you don't
sign no one like i'm big on like i don't
want to own nobody [ __ ] and i don't want
to be responsible for nobody [ __ ] and i
don't like commitments like if i'm not
[ __ ] with it i want to just be able
to wash your hands and walk away hey bro
we did our thing that was great and
that's it you feel me so that's kind of
how we built the company just being like
what an artist [ __ ] needs you feel me
like an artist just needs help sometimes
they don't need to be committed for four
albums you just need an assistant some
assistance you feel me so there it is
man we'll listen
go follow him online
uh go get marlin seven
go stream it up we're about to do a
freestyle so that'll be another youtube
video
go check that out and uh man appreciate
you pulling up bro appreciate you look
forward to hearing this new music with
russ
and the kendrick lamar feature come on
man